right now NASA is exploring the Sun like
never before in 2018 it launched the
parker solar probe which is swooping to
within 6.2 million kilometers of the sun
surface the closest we've ever been but
what if we wanted an even closer look
[Music]
our first stop gets pretty hot at 7
million to 10 million kilometers above
the Sun surface we reach the corona the
outermost layer of the Sun it blazes at
1 million degrees Celsius nearly 900
times as hot as lava and it's tens of
thousands of times brighter here than on
earth
now the probes heat shield works like a
very good mirror reflecting 99.9% of the
incoming light but we'll need something
even better as we get closer at about
3000 kilometers above the surface we
reach the chromosphere the second layer
of the Sun see that massive plume that's
called a solar prominence these loops of
gas are suspended by a powerful magnetic
field and stretch for tens of thousands
of kilometres beyond the Sun and they
can reach over 10,000 degrees Celsius
exactly the sort of obstacle you'd want
to avoid when flying a spacecraft into
the Sun and the next layer is just as
perilous the photosphere this is the
surface of the Sun we see every day down
here you'll start to feel pretty lousy
because the Sun's gravity is so strong a
150-pound person on earth we'd weigh
about 4000 pounds here that's nearly the
same as a rhino if you could land here
all that extra weight would crush your
bones and pulverize your internal organs
but if you take a look around there's
nothing here for you to actually
and on because the Sun doesn't have any
solid surface to speak of it's just a
giant ball of hydrogen and helium gas so
instead of landing on the photosphere
you're going to sink into it one of the
biggest dangers in the photosphere comes
from these enormous black spots you can
see as you look around these are called
sunspots they're cooler regions of gas
some as large as the entire earth the
sunspots are produced by powerful
magnetic fields coming from inside the
Sun which on one hand would fry your
electronics but more importantly where
sunspot forms a solar flare often
follows that's when magnetic fields and
super hot gas violently erupt from the
surface releasing as much energy as ten
billion hydrogen bombs
so let's steer clear of those active
regions and make our way to the sun's
interior just beneath the surface is the
convective zone here temperatures reach
two million degrees Celsius that's
hotter than your heat shield was
designed to handle in fact there's no
material on earth that could withstand
this heat the best we've got is a
compound called tantalum carbide which
could handle about four thousand degrees
Celsius max on earth we use it to coat
jet engine blades so even if we made it
this far we couldn't actually survive
down here but for curiosity's sake let's
keep going at 200 thousand kilometers
down we hit the radiative zone this is
the thickest layer of the Sun it makes
up almost half of the entire radius so
we'll be spending some time here which
isn't great because the pressure is at
least 100 million times greater than its
sea level on earth because it's so dense
there's not much room for light waves to
travel which means down here it's
pitch-black instead of travelling across
the radiative zone and hitting your eye
the light waves slam into electrons and
other particles in the plasma and some
even rebound inward towards our last
stop the core 500,000 kilometers below
the surface the center of the Sun makes
up nearly a quarter of its radius down
here the pressure has risen to more than
200 million times the pressure at sea
level on earth
pressing the surrounding atom so closely
together that it's about ten times
denser than iron plus it's a blistering
15 million degrees Celsius making it the
hottest place in the entire solar system
which makes sense because almost all of
the sun's immense energy is produced in
the core that's right
we're traveling through the powerhouse
of the Sun itself now contrary to
popular belief the Sun is not actually
on fire instead all that energy is
created through a nuclear reaction which
slams hydrogen atoms together to create
larger helium atoms and some extra
energy on the sides so even if you
managed to survive the blistering heat
the solar flares and the crushing
pressure you now have to climb out of
the solar system's biggest nuclear
reactor let's just say the odds are not
in your favor
maybe our closest encounter to the Sun
should be on the beach
you